(upbeat, lighthearted music)
- Have we had Vietnamese noodles?
- I am Vietnamese and
I've had quite a few.
- I've definitely never had pho,
and when I tell people that,
especially in LA, they gasp.
- Let's try some noods!
(easy music)
- [Men, Beanie And Glasses] Aw, damn.
- Smells like home.
- So is this pho?
- Yeah, it's pho.
- This is the most delightful hot tub.
Like I could just swim
in this and drink it.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Man] Do you pho-cks with it?
- I do pho-cks with it.
- I'm living right now.
- Beef tripe.
- Ooh, that's intestinal lining.
Mm, it's like eating
tender strands of a wallet.
- It's a very clean broth.
It's just a good way to, like, fix you up
after you've had too much to drink.
- Or if you get too pho-cked up,
pho-ll yourself up in the morning.
(upbeat music)
- [Beanie] This looks fuckin' delicious.
- It comes with an egg
roll? I'll take six.
- We were missing one key ingredient.
- Fish sauce.
- Ooh, that's dank.
- Kind of smells like a vet.
- So that's the thing about
a lot of Vietnamese dishes.
We just love to stuff
our dishes with veggies
and it kind of balances everything out.
It's a little symphony in your mouth.
- No, my finger, my
finger went in the sauce!
- Oh my god.
- Mm, that pork is good.
Did you try that pork yet?
- [Green shirt] Mm-mm.
- Oh, yeah.
- It's tender, it's flavorful.
- I feel like the fish
sauce is really imperative.
It just kinda, like,
weaves everything together
in a really good way.
(grunting)
(bouncing music)
- [Beanie] You say 'boom away'?
- [Off-Screen Man] Bún Bò Huế.
(start singing 'The Lion Sleeps
Tonight' by Solomon Linda)
- It's so festive.
- It's a lot of depth and
spice in it, it's really good.
- The fuck is that?
- That's not a lot.
- You don't need a lot.
- Alright, so we mix it in.
I think the shrimp taste
actually changed the game.
- It is more complicated,
but I don't know if I like it more,
because my mouth is on fire.
- The soup is a little spicy.
- I'm trying to stay calm,
but it's very spicy for me.
- No, no, you just made me laugh and it,
like, shot up to the back of my nose.
- Oh no.
- It's so spicy I'm dead.
(sniffing)
(laughing)
- They're all my favorite
but pho will always have a
special place in my heart.
- I'm very happy I finally got to try pho,
I will be ordering it the next time
I go way too hard at the club.
- We're not gonna start a
GoFundMe but someone else can,
it's called the 'Bring Zach
and Kieth to Vietnam fund'.
We will come, we will
eat all your noodles.
Thanks, we'll see you there.
- And the description of the
event is pho-ck Ned and Eugene.
- Fuckin' nailed it.
(poppy music)